I'm a dietitian and I'm going to show  you what I ordered from McDonald's for  lunch  can I get uh just like a hamburger no  onion  um and can you add uh mustard and  lettuce and tomatoes I'm gonna grab a  side of the apple slices and  um a mini fry yeah  okay so usually I go with their grilled  chicken wrap but for some reason they  didn't have any grilled chicken today so  we switched things up all right I got a  classic hamburger with extra vegetables  so I added some tomato and some lettuce  on top I also got a mini fry because I  don't need like a ton of fries but I  still need to get my McDonald's fry fix  also apple slices for some extra fiber  and a really great crunch factor and I  could not go to McDonald's without  trying out their new candy cane  chocolate McFlurry I don't even know  which one to go with first but I think  McFlurry  hmm  that is so Evan good